why watch annihilation or game night or
even rewatch black panther let's go
watch the vanishing of Sydney hall
instead guys we're gonna do a reason to
see him reasons not to see movie review
of this film that we went to I think it
was the premier genre I walked the red
carpet we had no idea we were going to
we were on our way to go inside the
theater then someone pulled us aside and
said wait we're supposed to bring you on
the carpet we're both oh really why we
let us cower the Getty Images archive
I'm sure in there somewhere and before
going into this want to give a thanks to
Jason Dolan who's actually under the
co-writers of this film flat out told me
beforehand and a text message is that if
we didn't like this you'd be more than
okay with us saying we don't like it and
when someone gives that door open I'm
more than willing to be like yeah have
issues with your filming reason to see
number uno Logan Lerman and Elle Fanning
before going into this review of should
probably give a little bit of a setup of
what the movies all about if you haven't
seen the trailer the vanishing of Sydney
Hall takes place over the course of
three different time lines all around
this one guy named Sydney Hall who's
played by Logan Lerman and you're
checking in with him at age 18 24 and 30
so 18 at the end of high school of
what's pretty much putting him on a path
to writing a great book the second
storyline is him post Fame and
successful author and then the third one
is more of Kyle Chandler story where
he's looking for Sydney all because he's
vanished he was this big huge author
who's gone disappearing for the past
five years so your intercutting between
all three stories here and you're
hopping around three different timelines
and there's also like a mystery
unraveling as to what led to this book
and why exactly did Sydney disappear and
there's a lot of other mystery questions
being set up as well I reminded me of
like a David Foster Wallace esque type
of thing but with a mystery and an
atypical plot structure put on top of it
and Logan Lerman I mean is terrific and
because you see Logan Lerman at three
different phases in this guy's life each
phase he is just as believable as the
next very often when you get an older
guy to be a high schooler it's or any
not that believable but this dude looks
like a kid in the movie we gotta meet
him in real life in a real life it
doesn't look like a little kid but in
the
he looks like a high schooler and he
feels like a high schooler each
different stage of this guy's life he's
a different person at that time and each
time we hop around time with this dude
he is so believable in it when he's in
high school when he is post Fame and who
has become at that point even in the
vanishing point when you finally get to
meet him where he's like all bearded out
in whatever even there I was like I
don't know if I'm gonna believe this
because I just I don't know if I could
buy this but when he started to get
lines when he starts to get scenes in
that performance you're like oh never
mind he is just as believable oh yeah
when we finally reconnect with him in
that third story I was very surprised by
how his mannerisms and even his voice
just just everything about his
performance really brought this whole
life together and that was something I
just wasn't expecting to be blown away
by this movie like he does a really
great job in every like you said in
every stage of the role and Elle Fanning
too complements him really really well
they have this romance that grows that
starts in the beginning in his high
school life and kind of grows to affect
every story moving on don't want to say
too much about how but each story their
relationship is different you do see her
in the adult years of Sydney Hall's life
as well yeah and when she's an adult and
when she's a kid
same thing like wow you are so
believable and both of these roles I'm
really curious as to how they directed
this film because with these time lapses
between these guys and the fact that
they're so damn believable in their
chemistry is undeniably great those two
performances alone I think absolutely
make this movie worth watching it's
called The Vanishing of Sydney Hall and
how's the guy who plays Sydney Hall he
is amazing he's so amazing I think prior
to watching this movie if I saw Logan
Lerman around either weird enough
Carragher approach member we're having
nervous to approach him but I thought he
was so good in this movie that I got
really nervous to go up to him good
thing he grabbed my ass me we were
taking that photo oh yeah that's what I
want to put that out there yeah he was
straight up doing no reason to see
number DOS the supporting cast there is
a supporting cast in this movie
everybody in this movie is really
terrific and that's another one of those
things I was kind of surprised by is
everyone's so natural and everyone's so
genuine we've got Kyle Chandler's like
this cop looking for Sydney Hall or like
a private
not really sure who he is he's in like
the Future story line to going for the
vanishing Sydney Hall and Kyle challenge
is great and in general and in this role
he does elevate it and there are some
damn good scenes with him in it man one
of my favorite scenes is with the guy
actual Nathan Lane plays Sydney halls
publisher and he's really funny and he's
probably only communicate care here in
yeah just flat out there to kind of make
you chuckle and Blake Jenner is in
Sydney Hall's high school story yeah and
he's like this bully who needs Sydney
Hall's help can't give too much away and
at first I was like oh god what cliche
bully and then after a while the
character gets to evolve and you do see
why they've got an actor like Blake
Jenner to be in this movie I met him
last night I don't know how to say his
name yah yah yah yah yah yah yah yah yah
yah yah Abdullah matina stand yeah yeah
Abdul Mateen he plays this teacher at
City Hall High School who takes a big
liking and really head of that teacher
has a lot of faith in in Sydney Hall and
his writing abilities the thing I told
the actor when I met him was you give
such a sincere performance what I found
so impressive about it is usually these
kind of roles I could find a little
creepy because it's that teacher who's
really taking a liking to a student yeah
but I realize that there's scenes in
this movie were not one thought I might
have popped up like this is a little
weird to me yeah it's just he has a
genuine grip on exactly what that role
should be like he's warm but he's also
clearly a bit of an authority figure
he's not too chummy but at the same time
I don't know I just love watching that
guy and also at Michelle Monaghan's in
this film she's not really utilized all
that like her character is an important
effect on Sydney Hall's character
because she's Sydney Hall's mom and
she's not really in the film honestly
probably not so like the last 30 40
minutes of the film where she actually
gets to be seen work do and she really
gets to shine as later and it was really
fascinating to see her in this role
because I'm used to Michelle Monaghan
usually being love interest character
something like mi3 if her Tom Cruise or
the Heartbreak Kid with Ben Stiller like
those kind of roles and this is a very
very mature role for her she sells it
man pretty intimidating movie character
in this movie
reason to see number three the writing
and structure I think the most
impressive thing about this because we
know the co-writer of the film around
when the movie was done aware that so
I'm like how though did you write this
movie at first it's a little hard to
adjust to they think I looked over at
John like ten minutes in the film go
there's a lot of time lapses in here and
then I realized oh we're watching you
three different time lines right now the
same guy the way they intertwine all
these different storylines in a way that
becomes fluid especially towards the end
of the movie because they're not just
watching three stories as you cut back
and forth between the stories are also
unraveling a mystery yeah and each time
something is brought up as a question a
mystery is unveiled or another questions
brought up when you cut back to a
different timeline and there's a lot of
intercutting going on eventually when
you when you adjust to it you're like
this is actually done really well I
think the structure of this film is very
impressive and super hard to accomplish
that's why we made sure to point out
here that the structure alone like the
outline on this baby super impressive
yeah would make me curious to see all
the different drafts and stuff because
it does do a good job of hopping between
three different timelines and once you
are just into it you know it does kind
of accentuate the mystery of all that
the cause and effect of everything and
learning which little details are gonna
come back and why I feel like they did a
pretty subtle job of most of that
there's not a lot of like look at this
object it's gonna come back you know
reasons not to see first half is a
little bumpy okay so the first half of
this film was really were like my main
issues actually like one thing that I
kept noticing is the the editing choices
were really off to me like the writing
and structure is great the
cinematography itself is actually pretty
good too it kind of gets better as the
movie goes I feel like yeah it's just
the way the editing is done I think
especially in the first half of the film
it's a little over edited and just the
scenes alone there's a little too much
cutting around I feel like there's some
shots so they could have just let the
camera roll or let this take just go on
and and but there's a lot of like let's
cut to a close-up under Nathan Lane then
a two-shot it's like that editing I
found a little uneven and
rather choppy in the first half of it
the time lapses and the time jumps do
take a little bit of adjusting too I
wish there was a little bit of a dunker
clean world he says like week one hurt
like this time so we really know what
we're hopping into it's not it is kind
of up to you to understand that messy
hair equals high school glasses and a
haircut equals author and from that to
and giant beard equals later and
eventually when when also the movie
starts to focus on the three storylines
and a little bit more of an even keel
the first part of the movie you are kind
of focusing on the young story in the
middle story and then a later story
comes in further into the movie in a
focal way yeah so that's what's cool
about the stretch or two in it but the
thing with the first half two is that in
the first half you do focus on all three
storylines I wasn't as pulled into post
fame storyline and vanishing Sydney haul
storyline until halfway it's no later
yeah it's probably like a solid halfway
point when you get a better view of the
situation you start to realize the
impacts of certain decisions and you've
seen already and where certain things
left might be leading the later
storylines do get a bit more grabby but
the high school storyline is thoroughly
interesting from beginning to end it
opens up the movie in a really funny way
actually
yeah and throughout the entire film the
high school storyline is easily my
favorite part of this movie because that
was easily the most gripping part reason
enough to see number two drawn-out
finale it might I add heavy finale this
is when the heavy move this is when the
finale the that's one of those indie
drama films we were like okay yeah this
is an indie drama where it's just a lot
of depressing [ __ ] just keeps piling on
top it needs to at the same time that's
the weird part about it there is a
degree I guess you could argue that
after a certain point you're like every
opportunity for something terrible to
happen yes
taken just like all the worst things
just keep happening in it like this
non-stop effect where I felt like they
could have kind of spaced it out a
little bit in the last half of the movie
instead of compacting it all into the
finale however I will say that they
don't leave any question a mystery
answer they answer everything because
there's a lot of questions and a lot of
mystery being laid out throughout this
film that at times when they decided to
answer something I was like oh yeah
forgot about that very important plot
yeah so it doesn't answer that yeah it
does kind of do that Lord of the Rings
thing where you're like oh yeah we got
to wrap this up and then we gotta wrap
that up and wrap that up so there are
some times where you're like oh still
going yeah but that would be our opinion
because like in the finale there's a
specific moments in it like I said it's
three storylines or specific moments I
could just hear a lot of people crying
okay there's a lot of people stuff so
what a heavy-ass crap the thing with me
though as a viewer I get to a point
where if it's like non-stop heaviness I
don't really get to it - your filled
moment I'm just like okay now I'm just
bummed yeah there is a certain element I
could have maybe used a little bit more
laughter or something there's there's at
least one good scene in here where two
characters like start cracking up
together and that reminded me of
something like of that warmth that would
have maybe added a bit more of a
contrast if there have been a little bit
more of that throughout or something
because it is very heavy movie ladies
very heavy movie the last like 30
minutes of this movie might make you
forget about some of the humorous parts
of it because there's a lot of humor
Nathan Lane there's humorous parts
especially with Elle Fanning there's a
lot of numerous parts in the high school
time just in like the opening scene and
the way Logan Lerman 's character is
there's humor in it it's just when
there's so much heaviness you kind of
forget about those lighter parts and I
get your point because in order for me
to get moved to it like a really
emotional set I'm like well I need I
need the contrast yeah it's hard to
argue because you are watching a
character with a pretty difficult life
he's been handed with a lot of coming
into contact with people who are going
through a lot of really rough things and
there is so much heavy subject matter
that they touch that you know I mean I
get that a life is this that can be this
way yeah because a lot of the themes
kind of remind me of place beyond the
pines in terms of like you got three
story lines except you're not just one
store a lot of time you're gonna cutting
and a lot of the themes deal with
choices and consequences what's behind
the curtain really things like that I
love those kinds of themes in a movie I
appreciated it and but the finale is a
little over bloated and while it's
intermittent like some stuff is really
like whoa and another stuff is yeah
in conclusion I would say that the
performance is alone and the impressive
structure of this film the way it's all
done it makes it worth alone if anything
if you don't even care about the writing
and structure yeah it's the performances
especially Logan Lerman and Elle Fanning
there are the main reasons I think you
you should check this movie yeah it's
it's something that I hope gets
recognized I mean I've seen a couple
reviews in for this and they're not been
incredibly friendly and I was a little
confused by that watching the movie
because I think there is so much good
work in a movie I mean there are a lot
of moments of really terrific writing I
can think of one bad performance even if
not every moment hits you there are a
lot of sequences moments scenes that are
very poignant very resonant I feel like
this movie might have done better when
they wrote it ten years ago or so you
know I feel like now might be a little
late for this kind of thing it's very
masculine movie it is a very male myth
kind of movie that being said though
there is a lot that's affecting about it
and like I said there's just so much
good work on display here yeah there it
is worth checking out especially if you
are just a person who enjoys a drama
that's why we do this pros and cons list
people because in conclusion with our
rating we will say there are more
reasons to see the vanishing of Sydney
hall than reasons not to see so by all
means go check it out alright guys well
did you not see the vanishing of Sydney
home I don't think you have yet you
should go check it out would you go
looking for logan lerman if he went
missing for a few years I certainly
would he has my number slip it into his
pocket you guys can subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell get notified every time one of our
videos is up and go check out our
patreon weekly Q&A s full-length music
video reactions and TV show reactions
over there a bunch of good stuff over
there so check it out